[Musique]
journée historique pour Paris journée
historique pour la France le maréchal a
tenu à venir assister à la cérémonie
religieus célébré à NotreDame à la
mémoire des victimes des derniers
bombardements sur le parv les
personnalités allemandes sont accueilles
par Monsieur
dobrinon
[Musique]
au grand portail Monsieur Pierre Laval
reçoit le chef de
[Musique]
l'État accompagné par Monseigneur Suard
le maréchal de France pénètre sous les
voûtes de la vieille cathédrale qui
depuis siècles a vécu toutes les gloires
de de notre histoire dans la ne sont
massé les familles de ceux qui ont péri
par sa présence en un tel lieu et en un
tel jour présence qui a toute la valeur
d'un symbole le chef de l'État en
désirant ainsi se placer au milieu de
ceux qui souffrent a voulu stigmatiser
solanellement la sauvagerie des
bombardements
[Musique]
terroristes
la pensée de tous les assistants se
tourne vers la nuit tragique où le fer
et le feu s' battir sur la
cité
après s'être incliné devant le chef de
l'État le cardinal archevêque de Paris
bénit le cénotap
[Musique]
Tricolore la locution du cardinal
su dans votre dernier message Monsieur
le Maréchal vous avez
dit
reste son
âme une âme qu'on ne saurait
tuer cette âme vit ici
elle s'est dressé dans la souffrance la
minute poignante de la sonnerie au
[Musique]
mort
la presse et la radio avaient tenu
secrète la venue du maréchal mais la
nouvelle miraculeusement s'est propagé
comme une traînée de poudre acclamation
monte sans fin vers le grand soldat vers
la haute et pure figure de légende qu
Philippe
[Applaudissements]
Pétin accompagné des deux préfets le
chef de l'État regagne l'hôtel de ville
où aura lieu le
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
déjeuner
devant l'hôtel de ville au début de
l'après-midi une foule immense s'est
massée tous ont compris l'importance
exceptionnelle du geste accompli par le
maréchal ayant à ses côté le président
Laval notre chef avec sa coutumière
simplicité va parler au peuple de
Paris je viens vous faire une
visite pas m'adresser à chacun de vous
en
particulier c'est impossible vous êtes
trop nombreux je pense à vous beaucoup
mais soyez sûr que dès que je le pourrai
je viendrai et alors ce sera une visite
officielle alors à bientôt
[Applaudissements]
j'espère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
la traversée triomphale de Paris par la
rue de rivolie et l'avenue de l'Opéra le
cortège se dirige vers l'hôpital Bicha
l'accueil vibrant des Parisiens ne fait
pas oublier au chef de l'État il est
venu aujourd'hui dans sa capitale afin
de prendre sa part de nos souffrances de
même qu'il y a 4 ans il f don de sa
personne pour le malheur de la
patrie
[Musique]
chev des blessés pas de grandes formule
mais des phrases comme lui seul les dire
pendant la visite l'explosion à
proximité d'une bombe à retardement
rappelle brutalement la tragédie
[Musique]
proche quelques instants dans son
appartement du squir de la tour maour
avant de repartir pour Vichy tout au
long du parcours les acclamations
montent encore vers lui aujourd'hui le
cœur de Paris a parlé Paris où depuis
tant de siècles bat le cœur de la France
et du fond de notre désarrois du fond de
notre malheur surgit un nouvel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
espoir